[Musique]
avec vous hélène frade bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour pauline à la une de la
presse à nouveau ce mardi la résistance
des ukrainiens toujours confronté aux
bombardements intensifs de l'armée russe
notamment à kharkiv dans l'est du pays
mieux que n'importe quelle carte
militaire sa peau mutilé sachar déchiré
recouverte d'un désinfectant vers prouve
la brutalité de l'invasion russe à la
une du times ce matin le visage de
jelena bahreïn tchenko 55 ans cette
habitante de kharkiv rencontrer dans un
hôpital a décrit au quotidien
britannique comment elle s'est retrouvée
projetée par un cyclone de verre et
d'éclats d'obus contre les murs de son
appartement touchée par un bombardement
russe il y a quatre jours si le visage
de jelena bahreïn tchenko illustre on le
voit les souffrances des ukrainiens et
les conséquences de la stratégie de
poutine ses compatriotes continuent
malgré tout de s'enrôler et de se
mobiliser dans un élan de solidarité et
de patriotisme
décuplée par l'invasion russe selon le
figaro qui voit dans cette résistance
ukrainienne la naissance d'une nation un
pays dont les quotidiens célèbre la
combativité face à l'armée russe à
l'image du journal ou cryan a mollo da
cité par courrier international qui se
réjouit de voir les informations sur
l'ukraine faire le tour de la terre est
noyée dans la honte je cite la russie
poutinienne certains éditorialistes
allant jusqu'à prédire le pire pour la
la fédération de russie à laquelle la
guerre en ukraine va mettre fin comme la
guerre d'afghanistan avait mis fin je
cite l urss le kremlin hélène qui a
proposé hier de mettre en place on en
parlait dans le journal des couloirs
humanitaires vers la russie et la
biélorussie et sans surprise l'ukraine a
rejeté l'offre de poutine annoncent deux
gardiennes qui rapporte vous l'avez dit
que le président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky a répondu en taxant son
homologue russe de cynisme une
accusation qui est relayée ce matin par
les dessinateurs de presse dont motorola
pour the times qui monteront loi des
ukrainiens à acculer dans un couloir de
plus en plus étroits comme dans le livre
de lewis carroll alice au pays des
merveilles un passage qui ressemble
davantage en réalité à un piège à une
impasse allusion aussi aux critiques
adressées aux autorités britanniques sur
leur manque d'humanité envers les
réfugiés d'ukrainiens les couloirs
humanitaires version poutine version
blower une route qui mène droit aux
enchères et dont les soldats russes
auraient les gardiens un dessin publié
par le daily telegraph
vous voyez comme je suis un bon gars je
vous donne le choix propose dans une
craignent à un poutine aux mains
ensanglantées dans le dessein de brian
est coque pour de délai
pardon le président russe qui se tient à
côté de lui le président biélorusse a
lui aussi du sang sur les mains
alexandre loukachenko seules les routes
1 qui mène chez eux semblent sur celle
qui mène vers l'ouest l'occident
l'europe elles sont parsemés des
cadavres de civils fuyant les
bombardements du en ukraine qui ont été
tués il me semble t'il à haïr pin on en
parlait hier l'europe hélène qui fait
face aux premières conséquences
économiques de cette guerre la flambée
des prix de l'énergie l'hypothèse émise
par les états unis d'un possible embargo
sur les hydroguides rocard burrus fait
planer une menace pour la reprise en
europe selon les échos qui font état de
l'opposition de l'allemagne très
dépendante on le sait de l'énergie russe
malgré les réticences allemandes les
pressions pour bannir les importations
de pétrole et de gaz russes augmenter le
quotidien espagnol el mundo indique que
washington cherche chercherait désormais
à négocier avec le venezuela qu'elle il
a imposé des sanctions sur ses
exportations pétrolières pour augmenter
sa production
la version écossaise du daily express
qui affiche son soutien au peuple
ukrainien cite pour sa part le plaidoyer
du ministre lituanien des affaires
étrangères
nous ne pouvons pas payer le pétrole et
le gaz russe avec le sang de l'ukraine
je le cite une déclaration qui semble
pauline recevoir l'assentiment du
tabloïd puisque le journal parle du prix
à payer pour vaincre poutine
la gare en ukraine hélène dans laquelle
les femmes aussi payé un très lourd
tribut c'est ce que rappelle ce matin
plusieurs quotidiens à travers le monde
en cette journée internationale des
droits des femmes le lait mars et à
cette occasion le quotidien italien la
stampa rente hommage aux fans
l'ukrainienne à toutes les femmes
d'ukraine qu'elle soit combattants
toumert que maria cette mère dont les
images ont fait le tour du monde
photographier en menant son bébé de 18
mois le petit kirill dans un hôpital de
mario paul l'enfant est finalement mort
de ses blessures des femmes comme maria
ou des petites filles comme amelia filmé
avec sa famille dans un sous-sol de kiev
en train de chanter libérer des livres
et du film la reine des neiges une vidéo
diffusée la semaine dernière et qui est
devenu viral depuis une journée au
féminin dans l'ombre de la guerre le
temps a choisi pour sa une la photo
d'une jeune femme venant tout juste
d'accoucher dans un hôpital de kiev sous
le fracas des bombes aujourd'hui les
fans se trouve sur le front et elles
sont nombreuses sur les routes de l'exil
rappelle le quotidien suisse des
milliers de mères attendent un enfant
qui ne viendra pas des épouses à marie
dont elles ne seront plus rien cela se
passe en ukraine en russie mais ailleurs
aussi qui pense encore au yémen où al
asiri merci beaucoup hélène c'était la
revue de presse